[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast
anthem mock I am a fashion designer and
I work very closely with some new leads
with this property business so today
we're gonna talk about how to create
opportunity and how to surround yourself
by face class people so that you can
take yourself to the next level mr.
Leeds mr. Mack how are you love
dude oh it's great to be sat with you
I'm very excited
yes buildings like the deed and one
thing I want to say you've helped me ask
me why what wire helps you because you
said a quote to me that's stuck and I
tell everyone this basically you know
got on to the business on the outside of
here yeah and you were like man not a
business if I can't function without ya
yes and I was like well I need to do
something about this so we've got more
people in to help my other business
outside of here
I know that's growing massively and now
I couldn't like commit more time for
this but not only that but you have also
got people involved in what you're doing
here
see see it a true business person can
also function in a business a good a
good anyone in business will always
replace themselves yes because most
people that are working as a member of
staff with it as an employee or whatever
they're scared to replace and stuff
because then they've made themself we
done done but actually if you place
yourself and you make yourself promoted
yes see this is big when you said that
because it's like I think I remember
saying now I know I'm a peaceful no one
can do what I'm doing you were like be
replaceable yes I was like so I was like
okay I'm gonna do it and then I found
some amazing people yes and now what was
I thought was big at the time is now
even bigger yes I'm getting people to do
more of the work and you didn't crazy
things outside of this a lot of this
company yes working with the BBC yeah
just finish with the x-factor tip
Britain's Got Talent got clothes go into
Hollywood's so it's amazing and when you
started working for this company you
were running around my clinic yes and a
training event was looking with the
Spice Girls what's working with the
Spice Girls when people said you're
crazy yeah because you should why are
you running around markrony get these
Samuel these events entrepreneur yeah
and that's something else that I learn
from your videos
and it's about like it's not about the
work you do and it's about just doing
everything you can to make things grow
yeah so it was like I was doing all
those wonderful jobs but I was living my
best life run of Mike's and learn about
all the things you are and you said to
me intuition yes like I did not have to
be there and I still don't have to be
here but I love what's going on it's and
you've transformed our company thank you
and everybody the speaks of you speaks
like so so well of you
all our property investors our students
they're in love with you and I'm in love
with you and I think that honestly dude
you're gonna go so far I think and you
already are you already have Oh Joe
what's good about that it's like I think
with property like the stuff that I've
learned from yourself it's not limited
to property now you have to be brave be
fearful take action I just applied all
the property knowledge that you offer
and just applied it to me the business
yeah so it was scary to get more
designers in and more people but it did
it and now it's like growing and people
are doing stuff one I'm doing something
else so the stuff that we're like
teaching is not just for property it's
like life start a lot of it is
transferable skills yeah no no in a good
business decision being able to replace
yourself systemize bump our teams in
place and work out the return on
investment make profit make money sell
use all this with me the business yeah
and you can literally apply it yeah
but I think like how you lead by example
is what people might see as a problem
there's not a problem because problems
don't exist
it's just lets make solutions yeah so
it's just like when you see you give
examples of like oh I can't do this
can't do that it's not I can't
it's like what can you do yeah how are
we gonna do it let's do it yeah and yeah
it's just how can i yeah I always say
average people avoid problems poor
people find problems and which people
solve them let's say you problems you're
gonna get rich or HSN what is it you
think what can you do to get past that
fear to make that big step because I
think that will holds lots of people by
especially when they think it comes out
like a big cost or something seems big
what you do to get
laughs yeah you get to the next day I
think maybe be scared of something else
like not doing it oh yeah so remember
the day life Shore and we're gonna be
dead we're gonna be dead soon in 100
years no one that's currently on this
planet will still be on the planet
definitely in 150 you could maybe but
you can't Bank on it okay cool and even
tomorrow so I just think instead of
saying I'm scared to do this because
it's gonna be a big investment or
because you are no wrong how's about
saying what if I don't walk at home then
what are the consequences of not doing
it yeah you know and also positive peer
pressure if you're surrounded by people
that are bums mmm and bringing you down
and saying it can't be done you can't do
that you can't they live it you know
then that's gonna make it really hard
for you to step out ways for me hanging
around people like you and the team and
everyone's a can-do person everyone's
making decisions making money like life
is short so I think is important to
always said then about like being around
the right people it's like so one of
like all of Lisa Meyer she was off
because she had stuff to attend to
outside away and she we text them wait
are you we want you back him we miss you
and she literally said she was nearly
rollin to work today because she
couldn't wait to get back in
yeah because of that energy yeah and I
just think like if you're not around
people who were looking at the bigger
picture you're actually doing yourself a
disservice yeah so I think you need to
be able to identify straight away it's
this good people to be around are these
good people to be around
yeah and I think what I like about with
what what we've done what our mission is
is it's like we're always looking at the
bigger picture
yeah like because that's what's most
important and we'll only let people in
on the team they've got the right energy
mm-hmm because of energy and attitude is
better than skill mm-hmm I mean if you
got both then it's really cool yeah I
but I think as well like I think it
comes back to the fear thing again if
you've got close bonds with people but
they're actually no good for you or to
holding you back or their small minds it
that takes guts to be like I don't want
this anymore
like I've caught off from like friends
I've been friends with sins like Nursery
and I've said your choices don't match
what I wanna be so you're gonna have to
just leave this
and I think you need to be brave if you
want big things because it comes at a
cost
yeah and it's like you've gotta throw
yourself I think so and also there's
some friends who you want to necessarily
have to cut off with but you can just
say I'm gonna spend two minutes with
this person not two hours yes yes yes
I've said that to be mom cuz you know
stop talking but it's like I think you
gotta be strict and I think like when I
first started doing some of the
trainings with yourself I was like this
is like what I do my bedroom like get up
dance have a boss moan and keep positive
and like fly through the day with that
and it's like some of the projects that
I do it's like I don't share them like
with me dads as much as I love them but
sometimes the human worry so it's I
don't want that lovely little project
being dampened by other people's yeah
less of a vision let them see your
results and also I think everyone has a
bad intention like with your dad for
instance is he trying to protect you all
yeah he's just oh you got enough money
oh but what happens is do that on a Mike
it's generational yeah I think it's
definitely don't you see how old are you
I'm 31 31 they're still kind of young
mm-hmm
sometime some kind of very very very
very look from our audience see on
YouTube the average listener
Emily varies we have 70 year olds and we
have young kids but the average listener
is around about 25 to 30 so you're kind
of the higher end of the spectrum of the
average I think I think when people try
and hold you back and of course man we
come across these all the time don't we
if people come to the crash course and
then they've got most people that come
to the crash course have been told at
least by one person not to be there
mm-hmm and then they're there and
they're like man I'm glad Nielsen
but it's other people that are trying to
protect them all its people that are
just jealous because when you step out
and start kicking ass in life you just
remind those old friends and one they
could have been actually good points on
that I was chatting to a fashion
consultant couple of weeks back
and the long story short said the work
for a property investment company blah
blah blah and then
just like oh we've just bought our house
and I was like uh-huh and now what it's
like no I'm done now I was like and then
you ain't done I was like why I just
sitting there like that ain't grown any
money so that's just there as I and he
was fighting his limitations today's
like listen come enjoy you knows and
just see what we're all about but
because of like where he was I would say
from like a generational thing he was
just not adamant to learn new stuff yeah
I think this is how it is this is how it
should be so which leads me question are
saying do with you being because you're
quite young yourself feel like 28 28 do
you find older people are reluctant to
listen because do you think oh you're
younger than me I know what I'm talking
about more yeah
it's really funny because I've never
found that to be the case mm-hmm and
when I started off training 90% of my
audience were over 40 hmm which a lot of
people that be like 50 years old maybe
the midlife crisis or they'll come for
divorce or they've thought you know what
this hasn't worked I'm making these
excuse me I'm making decent money but
I'm in the rat race I got kids now that
leaving home and they just wanted to
change but now how the majority of my
audience I'm more like 20s 30s yeah
hungry entrepreneurial but it's
obviously a mixture do people I don't
think they really can because if
someone's if someone's not earning what
I'm earning then I'm beating them
financially I'm only teaching them
financially I'm not teaching them about
life I'm not teaching them about how to
be a parent I might ask them about how
to be anything other than make money in
yeah I would say and I've done that very
successfully so I think if someone was
to come to the crash course and say oh
what do you know I'm older who cares
like if I wanted to learn how to speak
French I don't care if the person's
younger or older I care about how good
they are at speaking French and how good
they can teach that yeah so I don't
really find people concerned about me
being young I mean I'm more concerned
about am i doing property successfully
oh she's obvious yes and - am I good
trainer and the people getting results
off of my training programs dances yes
so I've already found that it's really
beautiful to see people come in that are
already property
because we get that as well we're
getting you've probably seen people come
to the crash course overloads they're
already property millionaires but
they're just coming because they know
when they yeah they want a new way and
they just think if I just learn one
thing just a little tweak and I'm gonna
make my money's worth and I really
respect and admire those people as well
yeah because it's easy to get
comfortable where you think oh yeah you
know I'm already a millionaire or I'm
already financially free but even me
today I'm still going on training
programs all of the time I'm reading
books I'm getting trained cuz cuz if
you're not hungry yeah absolutely
MC Joshua says stay hungry and stay
humble I love that yeah I just see the
fear in his face all the new info was
given um when he was just like you think
you need to sell this to me wife yeah
yeah but there was just that like see
once he wanted to take on what I was
saying of all the potentials but he was
just so scared and I just think it's
that fear thing again is because we've
been taught a load of crap
because the thing is growing up there's
everyone okay the government the
education system the media everyone
teaches us to be poor hmm we are
brainwashed and programs to be slaves to
the state oh yeah that's that's how it's
or even the banks it's all about work
hard save up money get good
qualifications generational again and
that's generational but the thing is
what I realize is the reason we've been
programmed to live like this don't ever
go into debt you know in fact the only
debt that's encouraged is usually bad
debt anyway you go to a bank they'll
give you a loan for a wedding but they
won't give you a loan for a house yeah
so it's like we're being brainwashed so
a wedding brings no return and they
won't gun I'll give you that but then
when it's a house like oh yeah so we've
been brainwashed and trained to be poor
so then because that's going in our mind
from the media education system the
government the bank's the elite all of
our lives as soon as someone start
speaking a bit differently people have
been trained to say it that's risky
mm-hmm if it sounds too good to be true
it probably is that's the most
ridiculous statement of the earth
because if you think if it sounds too
good to be true it probably is
then nothing good is ever gonna come
your life yeah you're just sabotaging
because it sounds to you good or
ridiculously self sabotaging a belief
system to have yeah and I think as well
you need to like Bri
again like don't be scared to venture a
lot of people around you aren't doing
what you're doing
so like an example of that with me other
businesses I'm actually working with
virgin now virgin yeah yes so Richard
Branson's got a new night called
Scarlet Knights and basically when all
my friends had finished doing all their
projects and finished graduated and
stuff I was the only person who kept on
design and and developing and getting
new sort of collections on the way so
could have been like all me friends and
just oh god bad years over let's relax
but I was like now I want to keep going
so kept going and I made this design
then whacked her up online and then this
was the one of the office that was on
the BBC and then the only reason why
that off it was on the BBC is because a
push past all me friends and made
something new that got noticed that went
on television and then vage and gotten
touched from seeing that on the TV Wow
so from what stopped with all be friends
I'm and party and I wouldn't have
created that design and then it wouldn't
have got bagans attention yeah
so basically design and six looks for
their cruise ship that's going around
the world oh you're a dark horse I
thought it was I thought so to set me up
with this cuz when she went to Miami I
gets an email it was like verge of Miami
voyages I was like she may as well take
credit she's got me back and then spokes
inches like I'm gonna clue what you're
talking about and then when it
investigates the bit Mulder went or no
it was from the BBC but I know that come
from not being scared to break out of
what everyone else around me is doing
yeah cuz all friends and let's just have
a break I want to keep going on do you
sort of know if you have oh if you keep
having a break then you'll always be
broke yeah oh yeah yeah and when people
say to me Sally how can you miss how can
you miss your daughter's birthday pie or
how can you not go to this school player
happy you know go to your friend's
birthday party or whatever it might be
because because that's that I've chosen
mmm to be an entrepreneur to create your
own world and I'm gonna and I'm still
like that now I mean I listen man I have
the choice now if I want to
I'm going to I'm going to Phuket
Thailand in a couple days I'm spending
ten days just me and my wife I can do
that fine but please don't moan that
you're broke mmm if you go into all
these stupid
and you're going out to the community
and then you get drunk and you're waking
up at 12 the next day they live for the
weekend such a bum don't be a freakin
bomb and then complain to me that you
broke you know and people so often will
say to me no I'm struggling for money
wearing like a Louis Vuitton handbag
which is worth a thousand pounds listen
man get your priorities right
you should be only buying luxury stuff
with either if it's tax-deductible in
your business can pay for it fine or if
it's coming out of income that your
assets are making don't be buying stuff
yeah like fancy holidays unless it's
tax-deductible or it's coming out of the
passive income from your business
otherwise it's just dumb say and I think
all this knowledge like for me
I learnt all these things through Lynn
and about like property in houses and
stuff like that because it's it's back
to that point you seen before it's like
the skills that you can learn through
property you can transfer them yeah it's
a many different avenues so it's like
you were so scared or not when I wanted
to get you in the office full-time oh I
remember this and then I was fuming that
you got told exactly what I said and
then you just come off - it was like so
you don't want to make an office watch
it watch your beef and I think I was
like I'm just not used to working in an
office and un's don't make him an office
job then yeah normally we get turned
down from people but yeah the reason
what happened was you wanted to come
might run for us yeah because you wanted
to be in the environment yeah yeah yeah
and everything like that connections I
was worried that that would be lost then
then it become a corporate office job
yeah which is like it's and we were like
we want you you were so good and that's
the thing you want to be you want to be
embarrassingly good in whatever you do
and you want to be embarrassingly good
you not mean bother mm-hmm I tell you
right there tell me if you want a
promotion don't ask for a promotion be
so good that it becomes embarrassing for
your manager not to promote you oh
that's cool like that if you want to do
business with someone I'll do a joint
venture partner don't ask them to give
you money give them so much advice and
value that it becomes embarrassing for
them to choose somebody else are the
over you people say to me Samuel how do
you get so much business how do you make
so much money because I give so much
value it becomes embarrassing
oh yeah people afflicting with the crash
course people say you give too much
stuff yeah it's like I think this is how
we run yeah you want to give them as
much as you can and people sometimes
come to me they say I'm financially free
just from your free crash course you're
free books you're free EEG videos what
can I do some guy was in today with that
just stuff a crash course
what can how can I give back okay cool
what what is it they're embarrassed mmm
they just I'm gonna say embarrassed
obviously I'm speaking in a positive way
yeah and you again you would come in and
my trainer embarrassingly good I have
good trainers on the fella very good and
then and then and then we're like I
think the CEO Sarah said to me what do
you think about and I said he's
embarrassing me good she said let's even
get him in full-time she says to me he
said no things going on and then I just
picked up the phone and said to you dude
what's happening and you said over on an
office job more than comm full-time but
don't make it an office job at all this
to me Mom yeah he's like yes just like
what you say to that but do you want to
get started you were like good I'll see
you in the office bro
but I think is well lay with because not
many people see what goes on not
officers so it's like they see
everything that goes on at the event and
I think like even for me I was like I
was just being observe and support at
all okay let's see if the proofs in the
pudding with all this because obviously
it was like they're micro numbers like
something I was doing on the side of
what was doing stat this free time and I
think like and lots of people say as
well it's like people want to come in
and the culture is not like officee it's
like mission based yeah and I think
that's why I like it it's not like I
don't have to do anything it's like I
want to do it yeah and it's funny
because in the same way that you are
creating and building a business yeah
and you were doing a new investments and
all stuff that you're doing with all
these celebrity yeah
and you don't have to work in the
company we want you that's our mission
for everybody Richard Branson says train
your staff so well that they can leave
but treat them so well that they don't
want to
and and and and and I think that's just
so important and your I love about this
as well like I get lots of our property
clients who actually messaged me saying
I saw this on the TV saw that so I know
that all the people that I look after
know that that's true yes not just
because I am hearing them saying it
DC Everett nut goes on with all me TV
were yeah and they genuinely know that
that is rock and I'm here because I
actually want to be and the love what we
do and I love the clients that we've got
so I'm glad that there is everyone knows
that that's the case with that I'm not
come from a biased place it's like I
don't need to but no so that's also like
it's like the people look after the you
know the script yeah so what's your
strongest reason then what's your
strongest reason why I'm for which
working here or just in general
everything you do ever what do you get
out of bed for in the morning and birds
out so for my other business obviously
know including the nine o'clock morning
dance okay because we haven't danced
every morning right yeah well sometimes
it's aerobics
yeah that's not limited yeah yeah
sometimes the massages so you crash
course people don't think he's a special
we all get these massages yeah so so
it's that one or we have to we have to
dance like crazy we were all dancing on
the tables and the chairs how do you
start your day with a meditation or at
no no no I start with a boogie we have
two other people and the officers like
saying why do so we celebrate Emily
because there's always celebrate we
needed yeah we just enjoy life yeah so
sorry make some oh my why yeah so with
my other business yes it's mainly
focused that women yeah it's the makeup
women feel visible because there are
that lots of women they think and
society puts a pressure at a certain age
that they're not visible anymore and
this is a very in particular for mums or
people over the age of 20 or thoughts
pathology or theity they think that it's
all about youth culture yeah so like
that mission is about making women feel
visible which he feels very strongly
about yes and then like my way
Commission is it's it's never about
where it's about what you love to do so
it's like I love always trying to make
something better
yeah so it's like it's not very limited
to what a direct masala if you asked me
to brush your floor I will put a
Christmas hat on Belles and Beau's and
lab users and I'll brush your floor yes
it's always about how can you make
something better so it's not mission
specific it's like life specific yeah
any opportunity how can that go one step
above like that that would be my mission
oh I love that and you know what dude
you bring so much joy not only to me
personally but to the company thank you
much I love working with you I love it
too yes love it
[Music]
you
[Music]